he just turned 30 years old yesterday
and his story is interesting in that he
was
one of the few pitchers performers
whether you're a hitter or a pitcher one
of the few players
who considered signing with the major
league
franchise out of high school and decided
better of it
so he did pitch in the pacific league
in japan and then later signed with
the seattle mariners and tonight the
raids will get a look at him
three and three with a three six seven
earned run average here is
manuel margot that's a base hit
lined over the head of moore into right
center
hanniger with the pick up and the rays
put the leadoff man aboard
here's the rosarina 2-2 from kikuchi
swinging a miss
one away one on and one out for the
raise here in the top of the first
inning
next pitch to meadows grounded to the
left side through for a basic
margot is going to take a left turn at
second base he's on his way to third
he'll get their standing
so now the rays have two on and here's
diaz batting 259
as kikuchi from the set delivers the
first pitch is grounded towards short
could be two
fielded by crawford the second out to
turn to first is
not in time scoring on the play as margo
and the rays
take a one-nothing first inning lead
yandy diaz can get down that line pretty
well for a big man
and trying to limit the damage here in
the first inning here's the stretch and
again the o2 pitch swinging a miss
strike three got a second strikeout here
in the first inning he strikes out
brandon lau and that will retire the
side but the rays get one run
for the tampa bay rays it will be
michael walka making his eighth start of
the season the record even up one and
one era just over four and a half
39 and two thirds innings of work and
what you wonder here tonight
is how long is michael walker going to
go he came off the disable list on may
the 23rd his longest outing
innings wise his three longest as far as
number of pitches was 42
so i think dwayne you and i both have
come to the agreement if kevin cash
could get
four good innings out of him he would be
thrilled here's the next offer on the
way swinging a fly ball down the left
field line slicing
arose arena on the run it's one is going
to be dropping in for a base in a fair
ball in toward the corner
crawford coasting into second base with
the lead off double
rose arena trying to get to it could not
just bear down that left field line and
jp
on its second with a lead off double and
right away the mariners have the time
run aboard in scoring position
last night's hero the ninth inning kyle
seeger nice ace and a hole to have right
here's the stretch and the pitch
swinging a line drive over the head of
second baseman low in
right field rounding third heading home
is crawford the long throw to the plate
by marco
way up the third base line gets on by
the catcher backed up by the pitcher
walker
the throw to second seeger is in at
second base
jp had a huge head of steam coming
around third man he was halfway down at
the biggest stop sign i've ever seen
he just kept on chugging michael
giving up three hits here in the first
inning and again the one two on the way
to bauer swung on broken back ground
ball up the middle into left center
field for a base hit
here comes seeger on the score the
mariners have the lead 2-1
jake bowers breaks his bat but it he hit
it just hard enough to get through the
left side of the infield pass prosso the
only guy on the left side
so shed long junior trying to keep it
going two outs and a 3-2 pitcher to shed
long runners go
pitch base hit up the middle yes sir
here comes ty france
mariners have a 3-1 lead bowers to third
set long with another rbi
the mariners with some big knocks
they're in the first inning
so three runs are in and the mariners
are keeping the pressure on the veteran
right-hander michael walker
here's catcher luis terence the other
way look at this
an opposite field festival going on here
at t-mobile park
rbi luis terrence and the lead goes to
4-1
seattle 4-1 mariners france leading off
the bottom of the third the
deliveries swinging a line drive over
the leap of rosso the third baseman
and into the corner and left field
france rumbles into second base
and he stands up with a lead-off double
faces loaded one out
great opportunity for luis
slow roller that will
work for everybody basic terence and rbi
another run it's 5-1
mariners and the bases are still loaded
another rbi for terrence
jp crawford has doubled and scored he
has struck out he has been their best
hitter this month
with bowers and long and torrents aboard
one more out to limit the damage
his pitch swinging a ground ball diving
at second is
the shortstop walls he gets up and
throws to first for the out
so the miss hit went for a hit and the
bullet went for an out
all right so runner and scoring position
in tai france with two out
he's on its way and he struck him out
swinging down and
in and the slider takes care of bowers
and the mariners are turned away
in the fourth no runs they hit one left
and through four
here's the one two swing and a miss
strike three you want to talk about just
steamrolling a batter
98 top shelf cheese and kikuchi
strikes out diaz with some on it
his sixth punch out of the night five
one mariners two ounce bases clean top
of the six
the three two in the dirt cutter
misses low and it's a two out of one
allowed tonight is o
for two he has struck out twice the
pitch
swinging a ground ball skimming to
second base dylan moore has it easy flip
to jp
covering second base and you say kikuchi
has throttled this ray's offense he has
struck out six
and allowed just for run over six frames
or went to the counter runners lead at
first and second three infielders to the
right of second in the pitch
grounded right into the shift to brandon
lau goes to second out to turn to first
by walls
is in time for the double play i believe
it went four to six to three as seeger
hits into the inning ender trying to
tidy up here in the seventh
finish what has been an outstanding
performance 2-1 pitch
swinging a chopper bouncing to jp
crawford he charges
throws onto first plenty of time to get
manuel margot
you say kikuchi he's about to get a
standing ovation inside t-mobile park as
he walks off for the night
seven innings just one run aloud against
the first place tampa bay rays
barrett is leading the race 5-1 last try
for tampa bay and the mariners have big
right-hander drew stechenrider on the
mound looking for the final three outs
the stretch and the pitch on line drive
left field line and diving for the ball
and making the catch jake fraley
holy smokes fraley in
to left field for defense here in the
top of the ninth and man did he come up
with a beauty line drive toward the line
fraley
rider deals swinging him out that's your
ball game
meredith winning 5-1 they've won five at
their last six
they've taken the first two from the
defending american league champion tampa
bay ray
yeah this was a simple one tonight a lot
of offense in the first team
scoring four runs in the first